this episode is brought to you by curiositystream
curiositystream is a subscription streaming
service that offers thousands of fascinating
documentaries and non-fiction titles from some
of the world's best filmmakers including exclusive
originals there's no reality show nonsense here
just non-fiction entertainment enjoyed by millions
curiosity stream is available on many platforms
web app roku android xbox one smart tvs ios
chromecast amazon fire amazon kindle and apple tv
as well as being available worldwide now
look if you like my channel and i imagine
you might since you are watching it head
over to curiositystream and check out their
docu-series history by the numbers it's a very
interesting series that talks about some of
the people we've covered here on biographics as
well as some of the places that we talked about
on our sister channel geographics it's
great crossover stuff so you can go to
curiositystream.com forward slash biographics for
unlimited access the world's top documentaries
and non-fiction series and right now you guys can
use the promo code biographics and you'll get 25
off the cost of an annual subscription
which comes out to only 14.99
a year which is crazy cheap so click the link
below or go to curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics and save 25 right now making it 14.99
for the whole year and now back to today's video
she's one of the most important people in american
history the founding mother who helped shape the
newborn nation almost as profoundly as some
presidents the wife of john adams abigail
adams was many things the first second lady the
second first lady she was also one of only two
women to ever be both the wife of a president
and the mother of a president after her son john
quincy adams became the sixth commander-in-chief
but while we may remember her today for a role
in her husband and son's lives there was so much
more to abigail adams than her famous family a
voracious learner at a time when women were
seen primarily as baby making machines adams
was one of the best red people in the whole of
america she was also an incisive thinker penning
one of the nation's earliest most influential
opinions to equality yet this intellect came
with a hidden dark side one that would lead her
to support massive curtailment of civil liberties
founding mother thinker one time hate figure
this is the life of abigail adams american icon
born on the 22nd of november 1744 or november 11th
in the old-style julian calendar that was still
in use at the time abigail smith's family were
practically massachusetts royalty her maternal
grandfather or speaker of the massachusetts
assembly a title that it hold for 40 years while
her father william smith was a highly esteemed
local minister luckier still by the standards of
the time he was also incredibly progressive in
this era the idea of giving girls an education
was considered as ludicrous as the suit made
of custard they should be taught to do chores
and be marryable but stuff like books theology and
science well that was for boys but not in william
smith's household against his wife's wishes
abigail's dad pressed her to read not just poetry
and the works of john milton but also history
philosophy and more by the time she was 11 abigail
was extremely smart and extremely comfortable
in her smartness among william's friends she
was renowned for a back chat one even declared
half-jokingly you will either be a very good
woman or else a very bad one still while letting
abigail get the education she deserved was great
and all we should point out that william smith
wasn't completely progressive despite living way
up in massachusetts the family still owned slaves
four of them to be exact phoebe tom cato and tower
if you already know a bit about abigail john adams
and their son john quincy this might come as a bit
of a shock today all three are lauded for their
opposition to slavery yet abigail's position would
always be more complex than that of a husband and
son while she would support massachusetts as 1783
abolition laws she never regretted growing up
around four enslaved people in later life she
would even keep in touch with phoebe after she was
freed it said she even regarded her as a friend
but while william smith's progressive credentials
may have only applied to equality among the sexes
that still had one incredibly important impact in
abigail's life aged 11 her education was placed
in the hands of englishman richard cranch who
quickly developed a crush on her older sister
mary in 1759 cranch popped around to woo mary
with a friend in tow a balding 24 year old lawyer
with a developing belly and his own reputation as
an argumentative know-it-all that friend's name
was john adams and meeting him was destined to
change abigail's life well eventually it would
their first meeting you see was not a success tiny
abigail barely five feet tall was only 15 and john
was hardly a looker in fact the day ended with
john adams privately dismissing her as not fond
not frank not candid while abigail's mom
declared john vulgar and unmannered still
the meetings continued partly because the
adams's and the smiths were vaguely related
and partly because richard crench was determined
to get into mary's oldie timey pants finally
in 1761 something clicked at a social gathering
john suddenly found himself looking at the petite
intelligent forthright girl with new eyes eyes in
which the pupils had been replaced by cartoon love
hearts their subsequent engagement was long by the
stands at the time abigail's parents insisted that
she not wed until she was 18. at last on october
24 1764 the pair tied the knot and immediately
moved to john's place in nearby braintree today
the town of quincy just eight months later
their daughter naby was born two years after that
abigail gave birth to john quincy adams who'd
grow up to be the sixth president but for that to
happen america first needed to become independent
and both abigail and john were going to
have front row seats to the coming war
when people talk of the founding fathers there's
a tendency to paint them as being saints dudes
in fancy coats thinking deeply and conducting
themselves with utmost decorum but for those
actually around them the founding fathers weren't
abstract icons they were real people real people
who could sometimes be really annoying for abigail
adams that annoyance came from jon spending barely
any time at home instead vanishing for days on
into boston or even outside massachusetts for work
the result was abigail spending vast periods of
time alone time in which she was expected to raise
their children oversee the farm sought out the
finances and generally deal with everything it
was a grim life for a bright young woman one made
worse by jon repeatedly forgetting to write her
letters while away to be fair tim though john
adams had other things on his mind things like
the colonies deteriorating relationship with the
british one of the reasons john was having to move
about so much was because the stamp act attacks
on every piece of paper used had just been levied
causing his legal work to dry up while it would
be repealed in 1766 subsequent british attempts
to attack the colonists were driving things
to boiling point everybody could feel there
was a disaster looming and on march the 5th
1770 it finally arrived the boston massacre
was the killing of five unarmed men by british
soldiers after they were cornered by a yelling mob
by this time adams has had been living in boston
itself for two years two years in which abigail
was able to abate her loneliness somewhat and jon
was able to get into local politics the massacre
though took him to the big time but not in the way
they might think when the trial of the soldiers
came it was john who defended them arguing
they'd been provoked by the mob he won the case
the brits were acquitted naturally bostonians
were absolutely furious the entire family became
a flame of discontent to which a whole
bunch of angry moths were being drawn
but was abigail upset no not one bit despite
her growing anti-british sentiment abigail
fully supported her husband's decision to take
the case not just for the publicity boost it
gave his career but for the principles at stake
the last bit is important because abigail adams
wasn't merely a dutiful wife standing by her man
while she'd always defend her husband vociferously
she was also more than happy to slap him down when
she thought he was wrong as we'll soon see for now
though the case made jon's name starting him down
a twisting path that would in 1774 lead to him
being invited to the first continental congress
sadly for abigail that would mean even more time
stuck at home alone the next few months were
basically like watching a movie about all the
epic stuff you remember from your american
history class but one focused entirely on a
character forcibly kept away from all the epicness
as the congress formed and dissolved then reformed
again in the wake of the battles of lexington
and concord abigail adams found herself trapped
in the role of spectator while she used this
time to develop her political thinking helped
by correspondence with early feminists like
mercy otis warren it was mostly a baronere
in her life in one letter she called being stuck
on the sidelines my patriotic sacrifice so it was
practically a relief when the war hit their part
of massachusetts the outbreak of fighting upended
the lives of everyone in braintree not least
abigail adams as refugees streamed in she and
her son john quincy were able to stand on the lawl
and watch the distant battle of bunker hill with
war came more exciting work in secret letters
she informed john of british troop movements
at the massachusetts colony general court she
took up a post rooting out female spies and
women with pro-british sympathies yet the
challenge to abigail's life in those years
wouldn't be things becoming more exciting but
that she'd soon find herself more alone than ever
the years of the second continental congress were
hard ones for abigail adams while jon was off
making speeches and rocking a powdered wig she was
dealing with not just loneliness and the stress
of running a farming household but also a
heap of additional disasters there was the
smallpox outbreak of 1776 which got so bad that
abigail was forced to get the children inoculated
a terrifying decision in an era when inoculation
carried a small but significant risk of death
and there was the ever-present fear of an
armed attack in 1777 abigail lost an unborn
child while hiding from a british army rumored
to be bearing down on boston but we don't want
to give the impression that she was just some
passive actor buffeted by the winds of history
even in the depths of her despair abigail adams
was working to shape her nation's future most
remarkably this came in the form of her letters to
john demanding the soon-to-be independent congress
make equality one of its central pillars abigail c
neither guys who wrote the sentence we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men are created
equal were indeed just focusing on the equality of
men folk hence her remember the ladies letter of
march 1776 in which she both asked john to codify
female rights and threatened him if he didn't
saying if particular attention is not paid to
the ladies we are determined to foment a rebellion
and will not hold ourselves bound by any laws in
which we have no voice or representation nor was
she just interested in helping white women as far
back as 1774 abigail had written to john on the
issue of slavery telling him i wish my sincerely
that there was not a slave in the province it
always seemed to me to fight ourselves for what
we are robbing the negroes of who have as good a
right to freedom as we have for the era she lived
in this was radical stuff suggesting an america
where not just property only white guys but also
women and maybe even non-whites could have a stake
sadly it was too radical even jon brushed her
requests off when the declaration of independence
was signed it said nothing about women being equal
still the severing of ties with britain did at
least mean a load of shiny new posts and duties
and for john adams that meant once again vanishing
off and leaving his wife utterly alone between
1778 and 1783 john spent most of his time in
europe on various diplomatic missions taking their
sons john quincy and charles with him that meant
yet more empty months in which abigail was forced
to sit in the ant chamber of history missing
out on the action while her husband repeatedly
forgot to write if you grew up with the sanitized
version of their story you might remember hearing
how devoted to one another the atoms as were
and how much john admired abigail's intellect
while that's true it also misses out how utterly
crappy their relationship sometimes was in this
era of loneliness abigail told people she felt as
if she were widowed she even tried to find solace
in an unconsummated affair with a notorious ladies
man finally in 1784 she seems to have had enough
of just waiting around taking her daughter naby
with her abigail boarded a boat for europe leaving
war shattered america behind the move likely saved
a marriage for the next four years the adams has
lived together in london now at peace with the us
finally able to enjoy one another's company as one
of the couple's modern biographers joseph j ellis
writes of this time they learn to love each other
at an even deeper level than before and locked
that love in place and nothing they experienced
for the rest of their lives ever threatened
their mutual trust by the time they returned
to the now independent united states in 1788 the
era of abigail being just an observer of history
was over from now on she and her husband would
work together to shape events for millions
the first election in american history was
probably the most predictable running effectively
unopposed george washington became president
after a lengthy ballot process what was exciting
though was the race for vice presidents in this
era parties didn't really yet exist with the
primary divisions being between the federalists
who john adams supported and the anti-federalists
that meant no such thing as tickets with people
voting for a vp chosen by the presidential nominee
instead the vice presidency was dependent on the
votes of electors and in the end those electors
gave john adams a plurality the ascension of john
to the number two spot in the government made
abigail adams the first second lady in u.s history
although the term wasn't yet used at the time in
fact a lot of things that we associate with modern
elected government simply didn't exist the capital
for one thing was still new york a city abigail
admired and enjoyed living in unfortunately for
her it would switch to philadelphia after just one
year at a city she hated with miserable weather
that triggered her rheumatism as a result the
second lady would spend most of her time back
on their farm in braintree itself soon to be
renamed quincy another way governance differed
was that the vice president's family didn't
get any official help at all while washington
was given a modest home to live in and had the
resources to throw lavish parties the addamses
were forced to find themselves a house and pay for
everything since this coincided with abigail and
john having financial difficulties it meant living
a spartan existence on the fringes of society
continually ignored in favor of richer members
of the cabinet speaking of which that's one thing
that was similar to today's era the complete and
utter uselessness of the vp job while it might
have separated them abigail had been proud of her
husband's vital work in the continental congress
now they were both simply frustrated with his
meaningless position with john's inability to
even speak during senate debates the only good
thing about being veep was how it made him the
natural choice to become the next president we
say natural because again these were early days
and the concept of american democracy was still
pretty fragile when george washington announced
he would retire after two terms abigail
and john were basically all like great
it's our turn next and they were genuinely shocked
when they had to face a competitive election back
in 1793 john's old frenemy thomas jefferson had
quit as secretary of state over a rift between
the federalists and the anti-federalists now
jefferson joined forces with james madison to
found the democratic republican party it's these
dudes john would have to fight in america's first
competitive election for her part abigail
was so furious that jefferson was standing
against her husband that she cut off a long-term
correspondence with him they wouldn't write to
one another again for over a decade over november
and december 1796 the states held their elections
with 70 electoral college votes needed to win
jefferson nabbed 68 while john adams cinched it
with 71. unfortunately the weird system in place
at the time meant jefferson would now become vice
president and in the wake of a toxic election that
would clearly spell trouble abigail sought as much
despite revelling in her husband's victory she
seemed to instinctively know that the coming four
years would turn her into a lightning rod for
discontent i expect to be vilified and abused
she wrote to a friend predicting she would
figuratively be fastened up hand and foot and
tongue to be shot at as our quincy lads do at the
poor geese and turkeys it was a bleak assessment
of the state of american politics a dark vision
of what was to come unfortunately is also right
abigail adams became america's second first
lady on march the 4th 1797 at the age of 52.
it was the highest profile role that should hold
in her lifetime and that was a problem because if
there's one thing we know about abigail adams it's
that she was more than happy to speak her mind and
wars on her mind in 1797 was the way the press and
the democratic republicans were out for a husband
after a bruising election john adams assumed
office with his enemies determined to make him
fail the press was merciless in its treatment of
him when abigail adams responded with withering
condescension towards jefferson's followers the
press attacked her as well at times this edged
into dark territory because she found philadelphia
so unpleasant abigail was still spending a lot of
time in massachusetts this meant writing to john
to keep up to date but people started intercepting
their letters and publishing their contents a sort
of low-tech version of hacking someone's emails
perhaps unsurprisingly abigail was rather pissed
she began writing her own partisan attacks having
federalist newspapers publish anonymous
screeds kneecapping her opponents with her acid
tongue no doubt it was incredibly cathartic
yet it also did very little to help the knives
were out for the second president and in some
quarters everything the couple did was merely
another good excuse to drive the blade even
deeper there was the controversy over john
quincy who abigail had raised to be as bookish
as bright and as argumentative as she was traits
her husband assumed would serve the boy well as
ambassador to prussia unfortunately jqa's posting
abroad triggered cries of nepotism among jefferson
supporters then there were the controversies like
the xyz affair now we're not going to go into too
much depth on this because we'll probably cover it
in a future john adams video but the crib sheet
version is that america sent some diplomats to
france to try and sort out a brewing spat only for
those diplomats to be shaken down for a bribe by
three men working for the delightfully corrupt
foreign minister talarand the scandal was so
great that many pushed president adams to declare
war on france when he stopped short of formally
announcing a conflict anti-federalist partisans
declared abigail was influencing his judgment
to be honest in many ways she was today historians
the gabigal adams had a big hand in some of her
husband's picks for important roles and helped
nudge him on policy it's not for nothing that the
opposition's nickname of mrs president stuck she
really was a key player but not in the xyz affair
in this instance abigail stood against osborne
demanding john declare war on paris when it came
to the most notorious aspect of his presidency
of all though abigail would be firmly on john's
side by 1798 the country was so divided and the
undeclared quasi war with france so damaging that
the first couple were living in fear john of mass
civil disobedience abigail of violence committed
against their family hence the alien earned
seditions act an act abigail championed but one
that had gone down in infamy a vicious assault
on civil liberties the act was anti-immigrant
pro-executive power and extremely anti-free speech
the alien's part gave the president the power to
deport any foreigner he personally didn't like
a serious cudgel in a nation of immigrants but
the sedition's part was even worse intended to
stop partisan attacks the act basically banned
free speech and freedom of the press mandating
arrest for anyone who insulted the president
and adams used these powers leading democratic
republican newspapers were shut down and people
were put on trial including a congressman who
merely accused the president of being pompous
from abigail's perspective the act was exactly
what the nation needed a firm way for her husband
to punish those who wronged him but the crackdown
would have consequences neither of them could have
foreseen now newly energized the democratic
republicans were determined to make sure
john adams broke another historical record
the first one-term president in history
november 1800 saw the adams at last leave
hated philadelphia behind and relocate to
the new capital of washington dc unfortunately
the white house wasn't finished yet building
work was ongoing and there are cute anecdotes
of abigail hanging the families washing in the
incomplete east room but while it might have
been better than philly abigail and john's time
in the federal capital would be overshadowed
by misery the first dark cloud settled over
the white house on the 30th of november that
day abigail's son charles died of alcoholism
aged only 30. as you might imagine this was
heartbreaking not just because they'd lost a son
but because they'd lost him in such a senseless
self-destructive way yet there was already
another dark cloud already looming up to join the
first one which would soon soak the first lady
in a bit of rain held from october 31 to december
the 3rd the 1800 election was basically a re-run
of 1796 pitting john adams and the federalists
against jefferson's democratic republicans it even
ended with a similar score with the winning side
just edging to victory with 73 electoral votes
the difference is this time those all-important
extra votes went to thomas jefferson from a
historical perspective the election marked
the beginning of the greatest winning streak
in u.s history the democratic republicans
would now win every presidential election
until they imploded after 1824 a seven victory
run unmatched by any party since from abigail
adams's perspective though it marked nothing more
than the end of her husband's career the couple
left the white house in march 1801 and returned to
quincy massachusetts under a cloud of depression
but while it sucked to lose abigail was clear-eyed
about what it meant a few regrets she wrote to her
son at my age and with my bodily infirmities i
shall be happier at quincy in all likelihood she
was right back in massachusetts abigail found
herself freed from the partisan attacks from
the relentless politicking and ill feelings
she found time to write striking up a number
of correspondences remarkably this included thomas
jefferson after his daughter died in 1804 abigail
wrote to the president to offer her condolences
re-establishing contact between the two of them
although she'd always maintain that his vision
for america was the incorrect one she would come
around to seeing the man once again as a friend
of course the big thing happening around this time
was her son's rise just as john adams's star was
fading john quincy's was beginning to burn with
nuclear fire after switching allegiance to
the democratic republican party jqa became
ambassador to russia before settling in britain
and marrying an english woman throughout abigail
wrote to him as she had once to john offering
advice pressing her political convictions helping
guide and shape his path by 1818 the boy was back
living in the u.s and in the exalted position
of secretary of state for abigail this meant a
chance to bask in the glow of her son's success
to be proud of the up-and-coming politician that
she'd helped create yet she'd never get to see
him become president on october 28 1818 abigail
adams passed away at home from typhoid fever
she was 73. one of the last acts had been to
write a will defiantly bucking the laws at the
time that said all of her money and property
belonged to the man she was married to instead
she left nearly everything to her female relatives
if congress wouldn't dane to remember the ladies
then by god abigail would today abigail adams
remains a central figure in the early story of
america a woman so important that she's sometimes
referred to as a founding mother in a way that's
a little surprising as vital as she was to
jon and john quincy's political development
her most passionately held beliefs failed to
make their mark congress forgot the ladies and
slavery wouldn't be abolished until decades
after she died but perhaps what's important
is that she pushed these ideas regardless that she
fought to make the new nation the best version of
itself that it could possibly be she might
not have succeeded but by trying she set a
powerful example one that would inspire not just
future americans but people all over the world
you